okay well what's this energetic battle
happening
all right we're doing it um
it's it's kind of a battle between light
and dark and it's happening at a
physical and at a non-physical level
and
essentially we want to come out on the
other end of it on the other side of it
uh in unity consciousness um
and unity really means both light and
dark
living together in harmony so a lot of
people think that like 5d frequency is
this other world this other place this
you know butterflies and rainbows and
aura
you know vibrations
and and it is when you're in it but the
way that i kind of like to describe the
fifth dimension frequency is it's a
perception change
and eventually when you change your
mindset and you change your perception
your physical reality will change with
it and it takes a lot longer for that
physical reality to shift into the
highest vibrational alignment because
the physical world is dense as we all
know and it's just a slower vibration so
you may take three years to manifest a
new living situation but to change your
mindset is momentary and so what's
happening on planet earth is the
vibrational frequency the energy on
planet earth is changing it's going from
a very low vibration a very dense
vibration a very linear vibration
and by that i mean it's
all this or all that it's all or nothing
it's black or white it's right or wrong
that's the linear it's the past or the
future whereas where we're moving is
once again is a unified energy this
unified field which is it's yes and no
it's right and wrong it's black and
white it's high and low vibration
and so we enter into this state which is
kind of this quantum simultaneous state
and it can be very overwhelming for
people to enter into a state where
everything exists simultaneously it's
kind of like multitasking but in your
reality
so when we're talking about the
the
energetic battle
being more specific
are there like i feel like i've heard
about
if your low vibration is low that it is
like an entry point for entities to be
able to feed off of your energy and when
your energy levels high enough they
can't feed off of you so it's like an
exponential downward spiral
um so
if that's true then what what do you is
that part of the energetic battle
and what is what is trying to take your
energy
yeah so definitely like other entities
um even extraterrestrial beings who are
not of a higher vibration when you're in
a low vibration or you're separated from
that source energy then um you're very
greedy you're very kind of
individualistic and you're just looking
for power and control and you're hungry
for that and so that's what these
entities gravitate towards they
gravitate towards the light they
gravitate towards the high vibration so
that they can essentially feed off of it
as gross and creepy as that sounds it
actually does happen and there have been
many different
um historical records of
whether it be monsters or entities or
you know nightmarish kind of things
there have been you know records of
these things purported in many different
kind of timelines in human history along
with religion of course we know you know
the demons and all of that um and so i
truly believe that we can all kind of go
within discern the energy that is coming
in and we can stand in our power and
raise our vibration which does um shift
our our energy away from the lower
vibrations which also like you mentioned
doesn't allow these entities or energies
to hang on to us um so this basically
it's there's a lot of information with
the energetic battle but
at the end at the end
uh humanity as a whole is meant to make
a decision and the reason why there's a
lot of extraterrestrial presence around
this um and around planet earth there's
a reason the reason why there's like a
lot of emphasis around this kind of
battle at this time is because we do
have to make a choice whether we're
going to continue this separation
continue the darkness continue the
individuality or if we want to move into
that kind of upper um higher vibrational
unity and uh and and it has huge effects
for the rest of the universe depending
on what we choose
and you know if we're gonna go there i
truly believe that human beings are a
hybrid species which means that i
believe that there was a missing link
back in our evolutionary progression and
that missing link was interdimensional
forces and i believe that they came in
and they messed with our dna and they
actually upgraded us with their dna and
because of this we are essentially the
children of these interdimensional
beings and as these children
um what i've channeled is that we are
actually a peace treaty so essentially
what we choose
based on the certain vibration that we
just embody right it's a choice but it's
also an embodiment
um that will actually have huge effects
on say the galactic federation the solar
system and this galaxy and beyond um
based on the fact that we are presented
with some of the lowest vibrational
energies in the universe and we are
presented with some of the highest
vibrational energies in the universe
and
and we're kind of like these children
like do you want to go to mummy or daddy
you know and like what direction do you
want to go in and that's ultimately our
choice and there's a lot of manipulating
factors that we have to be aware of that
have actually been implanted within
society for quite some time and that's
where you know the distractions and the
fears really come in and that's why we
see a lot of negativity at this time a
lot of polarity at this time
but likewise we see an increasing amount
of awakening souls and higher vibrations
so
why are we so important to
the galactic federation or to the
universe like why do we matter
in this giant universe multiverse where
there's trillions and trillions of
galaxies and
you know even more
zeros on the end to how many inhabitable
planets there probably are why why do we
matter yeah that was one of my first big
questions when i
uh ended up getting abducted at the age
of 18 and kind of blew the lid off of my
reality of oh my goodness
they do exist that they are here
uh why why us like you know
i i figured there's got to be something
else out there but why would they bother
with human beings like this ant like
species you know in the universe this
third dimensional archaic caveman kind
of you know civilization so that was one
of my biggest questions and once again
it comes back to this peace treaty so
from what the galactic federation has
relayed to me
for many many like millions if not
billions and trillions and beyond years
there has been an energetic battle
happening in the universe and if you
think about it there's all of these
beings all of these civilizations that
are in different dimensions and on
different planets
and the ones who are in higher vibration
is let's just all live in peace and
unity together and we do exist in a
binary or polarizing universe which
means that everywhere in the universe
there's going to be light and dark
there's going to be a difference um
which is a really great way to learn and
grow and get challenged and move forward
um so the light beings are let's live in
unison uh and in harmony with the
darkest aspects of the universe and the
lightest aspects right
and then the darkest aspects or the
darkest civilizations of this universe
are
screw that why would i live in harmony
with you and give up part of my
resources when i could just take your
resources
and add that kind of logical level i'm
like yeah i guess i could
you know
uh i guess
so but that's kind of where they come
from and what the galactic federation
has done and for those who don't maybe
know what the galactic federation is i
always kind of akin it to
um
uh like a galactic government for the
universe kind of like the un but like
less corrupt maybe a lot less corrupt
and they're just here to align the
different beings in the universe and the
civilizations in the universe to the
universal truth so one of the uh or
universal laws i should say one of the
universal laws is the law of
non-intervention which basically means
that no being is able to intervene or
take the free will away from another
being right so that sovereignty is so
important all throughout the universe
and what happens
in universal galactic history is these
lower vibrational beings continue to
intervene continue to manipulate
continue to take power resources energy
supplies whatever from other
civilizations
which is a huge no-no in the universe
and so the gfl has to basically come in
and like sort things out
and so there's been a lot of peace
treaties and you can think about these
old peace treaties as kind of like maybe
imagining like a piece of paper like two
you know um officials sit down and say
okay like we're gonna have peace for ten
thousand years i agree to this piece and
every single time the lower vibrational
beings always find a way to get greedy
and want more and override the peace
treaty contracts that is why
a very long time ago it was prophesized
in the galactic federation from a very
ancient mystic who said there is going
to be a civilization that is created
that is going to end the war of all wars
um
and
the and they didn't know what
civilization it was or how it was going
to come to be
but the mystic related the information
that this civilization was going to be
the
um the creation of uh once again some of
the lowest vibrational beings and some
of the highest vibrational beings in the
entire universe and us as these children
um with the very extreme polarity within
us the capabilities of really any
experience in the universe we then have
to make a decision but we have to be
free in order to make that choice and
what's taking place right here on planet
earth is all of the old systems that
were created to suppress and oppress us
and to keep us into a lower vibration
they're all crumbling and collapsing
because i believe that a lot of our
societal systems were put in place and
created by some of these lower
vibrational beings um to really trigger
us into the fight or flight to trigger
us into the survival kind of mentality
which is the lower vibration
and so as these systems are crumbling
and breaking down we're feeling more and
more free and more and more liberated
and i know 2020 was a lot for a lot of
people um but i believe that it was
exactly what humanity needed in order to
shift away from
what these norms are you know the nine
to five job you know all of a sudden
people are like maybe i don't want the
nine to five maybe i want to create my
own business maybe i want to have
freedoms in other ways and we're getting
away from the system that was really put
in place for us
[Music]